yep ping hello and welcome to another
tea session it's a somewhat shorter
session and smaller cup so let's get
going
or not 15 to 15 let's go but what if we
do
if we do a really quick one let's let's
do 1+1 yeah I know this is not the most
intuitive time control but I mean I'm
doing longer ones like Blitz 5 plus 3 15
minutes let's do 1 plus 1 session
if I get some opponents that is what is
my minimum to a thousand here that
should work
you
hmm if I don't get a game I'm going to
reconsider
I'm not getting a game
okay
yeah oh no I get one I said one plus one
one plus one yes that's it going oh wow
to adjust to that again you have done
much
it's recently not so much of one plus
one but I played quite a bit of that in
recent
recent month
so usually
Killah if I'm really not up to
[Music]
doing something serious work-related
then I'm sometimes just play him one of
one bit of one plus one if you could
rather he played that well I I did not
really register that is undermining
it's undermining c6m what is the thought
of him
sometimes don't don't quite understand
why time is spent the move looks
completely forced I still have him I
still have a good extra pawn
and a pretty sizeable advantage
it's not an automatic win
Knight f5 I wanted to play it is not
really doing much against it
seems like might wants to get g7 but
doesn't really do much no I'm
threatening 92 rook c2 all kinds of
things hmm yeah 1+1 is a different kind
of bullet because of the increment it is
by far not as hectic
not this one
what is a good way to play this a couple
of things that I can do for sure
this doesn't look bad
King f4 g5 check I get the knight back
and at least her very
good luck ending let me think about this
for a moment yeah I can check him and
and take with check
now keep the pawns
get
is rolling
or many
it's got no counter play him
now the second pawn starts to
starts to roll
you
and just have to avoid stalemate witches
we
as possible so I'm going for a rematch
Jim
my MIDI for repertoire is really great
for for those quick time controls
because you can very much routinely dash
out moves quickly it's just a big plus
you know almost all the time playing the
same moves with the fianchetto and so on
what black is doing is frankly speaking
a little bit ridiculous because I'm not
getting mated on the edge farm
and then to Kwong's up already
that's a piece body
so see that he cannot castle
hmm
we'll see six is a tech
[Music]
you
show
pretty much
all them
where is the mate
[Music]
really too blind to see them made
we had
you
it's no maid but I'm winning winning
everything
you
yeah with increment this is a bit
pointless
usually stopping matches if something
like that happens because this is just a
waste of time
cause I mean the one second increment
really um makes that very easy
Kim so let's go for a new opponent
in particular in the video that makes
relatively little sense
cover cover stuff like that
it's actually not easy to get games even
though I'm
I set the minimum on 2 mm it's not so
easy to get one plus one at some yeah
maybe not the best of ideas
about three plus two then let's go three
plus two
unlike from the button that always seems
to
[Music]
work even quicker
or not okay now we got a game
you
the my d4 upper twice also pretty much
applicable after one night f3 it's very
very often just transposes they should
have played maybe age three okay he's
just taking him
these kind of positions are of course
very solid for black it's um not really
something where you can expect much of
an advantage when you're white
playing this in a very slow fashion
interesting
- what he wants to do them
Wow
almost like a pre-move yeah
I can go h4h three
you know I can just allow him to go age
form
yeah I don't like to just allow each
form like that I want to have g4 as a
reply
I was going back with the Queen em if
you understand the point behind us let
me know I don't I don't do it
I want to understand the point there
must be some idea but is going back
again
okay
yes
yeah this is like the most normal move
he's going back there okay yeah let let
me take the space
and you can also think about f4 I think
I would do that just shut down if five
that looks very strange actually
why would you
take away your only porn porn lever with
b6
you know anyway I don't really mind
let's double on their farm this is
probably one of those super long games
where black will never ever pose a
threat
and I'm going to grind him down unless
I'm blundering something yeah very long
term there's g4g 5fo I'm like a complete
completely pushed back but for for the
moment I can simply play a play for the
Ava
you
yeah maybe he's going for Bishop c7 him
I think I'm going to go Queen a6 and
ultimately
and put pressure on c6
after the Queen trade route a6 it's not
so easy for him to to cover them I mean
it is easy for him to cover but it's
it's an inconvenient situation as what I
was trying to say
so I go gee Ford's has to be done anyway
gain more space now g5 and then ephors
the most
obvious thing to do
the rook s7 might also be good
threatening g5
now after
g5 hmm I wonder I wonder if I can
improve this position a little bit more
night-night should be approved and my
bishop on c3 should be improved
should probably go to
[Music]
go to H form yes let's do that or to g3
something like that
see threatening some something I don't
see it at the moment
can I go to h4s tactic that the bishop
is unprotected on that square
maybe I'm just making sure
[Music]
aha now he just goes back so Knight will
probably go to e7 I guess
I should regroup that to d3
- going for f5 No
not going to trade
you
Oh
you
no no trade please
you
it just can be annoying here and here
and a half so I have time
[Music]
you
it's not actually clear that night - if
I have this accomplish anything
to have six membership is probably
yet to me
to placed him
I also have the idea to play f5 in this
position let's do it yeah I would like
to have more time you of course that
would be definitely helpful we really
figure it out yeah how I'm going to tear
this apart
it looks good though if it takes night a
form got night is six and sometimes also
there are immediate immediate issues
with with Bishop h5 check for example
you know I'm probably missing something
here because because of the time
situation
okay so I mean winning a bit of material
here
[Music]
you
it's just a check
patek the pawns one by one
you
now where are you going with this
now a drupe takes h7
so equals for spycheck only form
you
you know I got 14 seconds that is
plenty
YUM
after b5 that was a very one-sided
affair really
like was slowly ground down
this is a very good line against one g3
while similar setups that I have played
a lot over the years it's some not going
to refute wide set up for sure not but
it is just so easy to play
you always get this kind of kind of
formation and you know you always ask at
least that is what I'm doing I'm always
wondering what exactly is why it's idea
in this position you're just sitting
there
okay I often took with the bishop in
these situations a bit uncommon maybe
but
okay Bishop takes age six could be a be
an idea here
with them
check and 95 both armed
[Music]
both are possible I think we six credits
work
Bishop h6 bishop before Bishop g7 okay
where are you going him No
what's the deal
now it's e3 is a bit odd don't know
where he's heading with it
a nice D for I think this is I know he
can take you five
you
yeah I got time you don't need to rush
anything
Knight f5 2d form maybe ultimately I
want the night on deform typical outpost
okay it doesn't look like he's got
particularly useful in store
just 94 I guess so
you
yeah going for the space
five and then f5 something like that
should happen next
pushing white back the only active idea
that he has is some 95 stuff actually
interesting
doesn't quite work but
it's something that I have to check I
mean for example I cannot just go f5
because of Nagi five chick
okay some should be five should be two
as a bit mysterious
not sure what the point of this move is
you
y-you have to go back now right
- doesn't work
9200 create
just enjoying the
and a nice space advantage
hmm what's 95 maybe on in this position
not quite but
or close
the point of this move is probably to go
to a five here in this position
except that the case
be 595 looks odd
you
okay Quincy six is one interesting move
and then he has to move the night too
and not too attractive square but I also
have rookie tool I think the rupee - is
probably even better
mmm I could take
see - now right let's take the porn
sorry
voice is a bit off
or Queens is six actually now why not
now against night you want to actually
have a check I can take with check
so it goes to H form
after which I could take click whenever
3y can take on c2
you know maybe
[Music]
um
I'm just taking taking everything him
and now after it be alert night f-4s is
on
now it could be
annoying
ulam
considering that my king with f5 is
slightly weakened
oh this is hanging
shoot
I'm a little bit nervous here due to the
time position is of course nice still
even after the blunder it's nice but not
as good as it was
the very beginning that was just
completely completely lost
a couple of months ago I mean
we know for as my threat here
queen of form
he more or less has to take on f3
everything is covered
that is what is the best way to do this
Queen we know for probably still
yeah
made
or something like this
you
yeah never looked okay so with two games
against this guy
let's play maybe more and somebody else
um okay it's go evil
just a bit of a challenge for myself
something completely different
I can't play this kind of grandma
grandpa set up against the dragon it's
not the most challenging one for sherbet
I don't think I would be able to
[Music]
to play the sharp lines without knowing
the theory
is a five maybe a mafia ii five night
xp3
takes on f6
any right let's do this
isn't that a piece
I had an idea it's not like if I was
completely random
yeah night b3e f6 should be good for
white I guess
okay so rematch I want a quick one
you
if three is bit weird at this particular
moment
doesn't really fit into into this
position
as such a structure wouldn't be that bad
for white but he's got f3 plate and that
weakens the whole position pretty
severely why is that not losing a piece
Oh
you
okay so queen 8 593 d4
it should be seven
ninety-seven
and then a queen move
Wow what a lucky guy
really lucky him that he blundered dead
completely but it's not immediately lost
okay after I still think it's good for
me
you
yeah what else okay so d4 Bishop d7
I guess King D 7 yeah Knight takes there
is even Queen e4 which is really odd but
seems to work maybe there are even other
tactics here I just see night
I'll just see Queen e5 and this
pollution
Wow
okay
so I'm taking with the king
hmm yeah I thought this this would
probably be bad news for the night I
think this was all in all not not well
played by ABBA me
a couple of things possible for wide
okay now
first of warm
go here
[Music]
don't know if I want to go a six as such
such a lame move
now it's problem
easy to do easy to play
rook c8 eventing 94
you
okay
what do we do this probably here
f5
attending a forum
the main issue really is the night on a
3 which is just completely our two out
of the game
oh okay
maybe now it's good time to take
actually before night see for happens
but this is a tough tough decision
because everything is a huge advantage
basically
you
I got 93 that would already win quite a
good chunk of material
wins the exchange form
too much I just wonder if it's the best
Abdi Nora if I do this he more or less
has to go before and this looks
completely terrible
you
mmm
maybe this one actually that comes with
the tempo
and night takes and take on a voice
any easier think
never just spoiled for choice everything
is fantastic for black
so I'm going to take a form
Knight always has a square on c3 or b2
you
maybe rookie seventh first
okay now are we going to promote nice
yes night I'm sorry
look d5 check maybe
something that I can prevent
you
Oh
wasn't really around that
time was going down a bit
it's not promoting on its own
unfortunately
and go to the seventh
what's that
HM not so happy with how I played this
it looks like white is getting a little
bit more play than
it was necessary to allow him
yeah let's push this home
the pawns should really promote on their
own he's got
the bishop on a five
you
ah there's a bishop only one I'm so
stupid
my god
what is he doing here
that was very strange
the whole sequence was very strange
you
yeah it has the right result but I was
completely completely dumb
you
I just have to briefly revisit that yeah
I completely I completely overlooked
that he's on that twice yeah
that is so stupid I can just take be
five or whatever or d2 was also winning
I just completely forgot that he's on
that after that is probably yeah rook
takes the one would even win Bishop
takes a silly draw
oh my it was there was really odd okay
I'm going to stop the video now it's a
pre-recorded one as I already mentioned
I'm away while this is released so
thanks a lot for watching bye bye guys
you